good
morning millennials good morning brother
good morning brother good morning
grandmother good morning my grandsons
you are looking
ravishing this morning grandmother you
as well you look so
beautiful grandmother we are so happy to
see you thank you for having me
no i can't keep the accent you are the
most
radiant woman in all of great britain
thank you
so much that's what they tell me yes we
love you so much grandmother
you brother are another story oh i'm
another story
broke the family apart disrespected the
crown
and i'm the problem grandmother can you
believe this
what bollocks bloody [ __ ]
you know that's not what happened that's
exactly what happened my my harry
grandmother whose side are you on harry
william
harry why don't you go back to canada or
whatever it is you're
los angeles yeah gallivanting around the
country while your duties wait for you
at home
don't you miss your duties no i have
enough
duties on my own well
just know all of us back home are
picking up the slack where you and your
wife
left us i'm sorry brother i am sorry but
i couldn't do it anymore
yeah i couldn't do it anymore do you
know how much
do you know how much i would give to be
you no responsibility
no care in the world you know how much i
would give to be you to be the
heir not the spare oh what i would give
to be the spare
let's switch the prince switch good
morning everyone in case you haven't
noticed the windsor family is coming to
you live and in living color
from the toast studios happy halloween
everyone woo-hoo happy halloween happy
toast to eating grandmother we love you
we got the snitching studio
give it up for grandmother
snitch how do you do you are being
[ __ ] crazy like you know when you put
on a costume and like it kind of gets to
you like
harry's getting to you and like i didn't
know what kind of harry i was going to
be but i just feel like this like party
boy
really checked out where i'm just like
grandmother let's [ __ ] this
oh my god you're definitely channeling
like early 2000's sorry nothing like
he's not megan marco larry no he's not
like new fatherhood hats
no no no no no it's really yeah we have
about you right there you're really like
the rebel
harry rebel without a cause well we hope
you guys
enjoy our costumes this is now year four
year four wow that's crazy yep and
honestly this is my favorite one yet i'm
just like
really feeling my look like my linen
suit honestly the linen suit is like a
vibe on you
no i know i was like i'm gonna save the
suit for zach to try yeah
to a wedding on the beach or something
it's really a vibe i see why he
enjoys it so much yeah now fabulous
fabulous
bloody fabulous brevard you look
fabulous in your royal garb
well as you know part of being the next
heir to the throne
is my royal duties in the air force i
know you know nothing about that brother
so you can say you spent your formative
years in las vegas but
i have actually spent lots of time in
the air force
and it has been one of the most if not
the gratifying experience
of my life kate and i are uh
catherine and i are honored to have been
a part of the air force it's
quite a wonderful organization i'm happy
for you brother know that i am
okay grandmother in studio grandmother
is this your first podcast
good question it is yeah so we've got
queen elizabeth on the podcast just like
a little
spectacular grand what are your thoughts
on the podcasting medium
i think it's great i think it's a little
saturated however
i think that is great i think this is a
great one grand just
shading us gran just shook up the
industry
well we of course are delivering the
fast five we're giving you a regular
show today just in our
royal garden you know royal this is the
thing about royalty
and as william would say like it's just
something you're born into like it's not
a choice it's a lifestyle
yeah and i definitely feel that way like
i was meant to be royal the royal life
chooses you
and it chose me and i said no thank you
brother
that's exactly what you said you said
not today brother
no not today well we
you know i actually think it might be
beneficial for harry
to hear what's been going on at
buckingham palace since he's been
departed for canada
yes grandmother how has your quarantine
been it's been lovely i've had a lot of
cattle
i mean lots of lots of tea and you know
it just chilled with the staff
and to be quite honest the uh
the palace has how do you americans say
uh a better
vibe without you and megan
uh you know stinking up the place wow
brother
well the drama this has a great vibe for
me brother
i'm in hollywood
well brother all i can say is that your
presence is not missed
and the palace is doing better great
without you and that's
that's all we invited you here to say
brother good well when i
left the palace that's all that i wanted
i wanted the best for everyone
including me and my family how was the
the little
champ by the way oh he's such a cute
sweet
crunchy angel boy the man
he actually is really cute he's really
cute yeah he's really cute that's your
great great grandson
and brother and brother would you like
to ask
how my children are how is the
how is the family brother the family is
just delightful you know kate is just
popping them out left and right even
though
i didn't even know we had sex still but
she's just popping them out left right
left right it's [ __ ] wild
and the kids are just getting so big and
so annoying and
i just don't know what to do because i'm
from africa now
the accent's very hard yeah it was hard
to stay in it when you're so i literally
go from like
british to i feel french
part like the brits are very stayed like
not very emotional so when i'm just like
popping yeah
i just become like a cowboy no irish
yeah like
it's really hard not to just
automatically become southern like yeah
even though the regions are just not
that close no they're not
but you are the prince of wales well the
people of welsh
no the welsh people are some of my
favorite
what a wonderful providence i actually
province
province and i don't know if father ever
told you this story because he hates you
and he probably didn't
but he actually gave a speech in wales
in welsh and it was one of the most
defining moments of his career
the welsh are very proud people brother
yes i would expect nothing less you
sound like drake and josh
hug me brother hug me grandmother
um grandma can i have a hug sure okay
later you come here
um we actually have a great show because
we have fast five stories and
southern charm started last night as did
keeping up with the kardashians
so we've been keeping up with them
kardashian girls and very interesting
yes i've heard you and megan are really
trying to cozy up to that hollywood
scene
yes yes we've met kim before very
beautiful woman
yes very beautiful very uh how do you
americans say
uh
how do you what do we say how do you
americans say
she's very uh hot
hot hot i quite enjoy the kardashian
girls brother if you actually do end up
becoming acquaintances with her
do let me know i'll have to make a visit
to the states okay brother
um okay so i think maybe like without
further ado we should dive in
yeah let's dive in it's the toaster ween
we got some great stories for you today
so without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite of
your morning toast brother
and today's episode is brought to you by
palmer's new hemp oil calming relief
body oil
palmer's new hemp oil calming relief
body oil is hypoallergenic and
approve the hemp oil calming relief body
oil has proven clinical results and is
safe for sensitive and eczema prone skin
hemp oil calming relief oil seals in
moisture for up to 48 hours
in clinical trials 100 of women
reportedly reported visibly improved
skin texture
and increased skin elasticity um
palmer's is the most fabulous brand out
there like i've been using we've been
using the uh
cocoa butter sticks like forever forever
and i just feel like it's a really like
trusted brand like whatever they put out
like i am good with it and they have a
new hemp oil calming relief body lotion
that people are just absolutely loving
so e.t brown drug crab which is the 180
year old leader in the treatment
oriented beauty products
including palmer's cocoa butter formula
has launched hemp oil calming relief
body lotion
hemp seed oil calms inflammation and
soothes irritation leveraging the
healing power of nature
the hemp oil collection uses cocoa
butter and vitamin e ingredients to calm
soothe and hydrate all skin types so
it's perfect for eczema prone skin
it's free from mineral oils parabens
sulfates dyes and phlatholites and
animal ingredients
hypoallerge it's hypoallergenic and safe
for sensitive skin it's dermatologist
tested
and it's available at drug and math
stores nationwide beginning fall 2020
they come in eight ounce bottles and it
retails for eight
dollars again all drug stores and mass
stores
nationwide beginning fall 2020 make sure
to check out the new hemp oil calming
relief body lotion from pomo's
palmer's sorry literally just a fabulous
brand that like if you just want your
skin taken care of in every single
possible way you should definitely check
out
i love the calming relief oil from
palmer's because i'm very stressed
brother
meet you brother i have to be stressed
about the way would you look at me i
don't have any bloody hair talking to
you
i don't have any bloody hair grandmother
and you won't pay for the hair plugs so
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
grandmother
have the taxpayers pay for them oh my
god bloody hell i've been balding since
the time i was 12.
nobody in this [ __ ] palace seems to
give a [ __ ]
you don't have any money no grandmother
you hold the keys to my fortune and i
can't
go i've been trying to fly father i've
been asked your
father i've been trying to fly to turkey
for the last three years to get a
special hair plug procedure
but nobody in this [ __ ] cam family
cares about anything other than bloody
harry and his bloody [ __ ] drama
ask your father jesus sorry to take the
name lord's name and vain grandmother
but i'm upset
brother get a job oh do some instagram
sponsorships like the rest of them
not all of us can just rub elbows with
bob iger and make a 50 million
deal for our wives some of us obey the
rules
well brother look where it got you bald
that's so mean
i just feel like william's like
definitely deeply insecure about his
hair like nobody takes him seriously he
he could get [ __ ] fixed okay i know
but he can at this point because it
never it's too late
but then he'd be like he'd be a great
speaker for people that's great he'd be
his favorite
plugs i'm not really hating like the
bald look on me no i think you look
great i think he looks great
i think i look fabulous sorry brother i
didn't mean to uh
it's not very royal of me i apologize i
know you don't care about being royal
but some of us still do
excuse me i'm the duke of sussex [ __ ]
and not anymore
not anymore still i got that trademark
no you don't
no you can't use it stay tuned for merch
drop
whoo okay first story is about
us brother uh what is the british
tabloid saying about us again the press
is saying our royal rift was sealed by
fate and diana and you know brother that
makes me feel
better because this was destiny
what are you saying what's the story
bravo prince harry and prince william
were once the closest of friends they're
for each other through thick and thin
those were the days brother those were
the days
charmingly choosing to rent a cottage
together while training to become
helicopter pilots in 2009 that's so cute
and steamy
yeah quote i do a fair bit of tidying up
after him he snores a lot too he keeps
me up all night long william had said at
the time
just over a decade later jokes are on
thin ground
with william in london and harry and
montecito there are 5 500 miles between
them
they're also in incredibly different
headspaces quote the rift gets more
serious with every passing day
british historian robert lacy told the
post of the feud that caught fire after
harry and wife megan
quit the house of windsor in march so
the rift is just
it's astronomical how do we come back
from this brother how do we
come back to each other brother if i'm
going to be quite honest
i'm hap brother on a on a very serious
note i'm very happy for you
but i just feel as though you owe the
crown an apology
well brother i've been watching the
crown and i
agree bloody americans i agree
the crown is a wonderful institution
grandmother you are an icon
everything of the sort and i'm sorry if
i let you down but i had to do what was
best for my family and i'm sorry that
that was not what was best for this
family
but the monarchy is most important i
know you have to protect the monarchy
i will grant that you will
i'll protect the monarchy from montecito
high school
[Laughter]
i'm sorry brother i hope we can be close
again even though you just touched your
nose
[Laughter]
brother i i do i appreciate the
sentiment but
uh i'm afraid it's too late so the rift
runs deeper
the rift runs deeper the historian was
right i just
i hope that you know a hundred years
from now the monarchy
is not permanently changed because of
your actions and i
just i don't know how you sleep at night
i sleep quite well thank you with
palmer's health
but i understand i understand your
concern but i had to do what was best
for my family and i'll leave it at that
brother okay
also little royal news about mom and dad
prince charles felt dad prince philip
pushed him into marrying princess diana
the royal biographer says
this came out today and honestly this
doesn't sound like news i think we all
knew that especially if you watch the
crown but also if you just like
if you're just like or have a brain he
wanted to marry camiro camilla parker
right he couldn't he married diana
things didn't go well he eventually
married camilla
but i guess that's news because this
royal biography
is saying that he told some of his
friends that he felt pressurized
into marrying diana because philip said
you've either got to marry her or let
her go
you can't string a young girl along
she's only 19 you can't string her along
that's actually good advice though that
is good advice and i think that's
literally exactly what we'll see in the
season of the crown premiering november
15th
ooh i gotta catch up speaking of royal
you are the crown grandmother it's in
your head
yeah speaking of royal autobiographies
uh bravo i meant to
tell you i had a chance to read your
non-affiliated autobiography founding
freedom
um and i just have to say what a crock
of [ __ ]
croc croco of poo of yeah of poo
real uh how do you americans say uh
propaganda
i don't know why my accent keeps going
in and out like um
yes brother i know
but i had to get my story out there yes
i understand
feels like a gang up on harry well
well you've been gone for so long
brother we haven't had an opportunity to
uh
talk to you about all the drummings and
the uh
circuit de soleil around your family and
your name
gran you said a swear word oh gran
said a swear word grant said a swear
word
[Music]
gran that's a nickel in the swear jar
yeah gran
[Laughter]
okay next story some big news in my
country of america
jost married scarlett johansson and
colin jost tie the
knot in an intimate ceremony
scarlett and colin jost have officially
said i do the couple tied the knot in an
intimate ceremony over the weekend the
instagram account for meals on wheels
america announced on thursday
right that's what's i'm confused about
so
meals on wheels broke the story saying
we're thrilled to break the news that
scarlett johansson and colin jost were
married over the weekend in an intimate
ceremony with their immediately
immediate family and loved ones
following coven 19 safety precautions
as directed by the cdc their wedding
wish is to help make a difference for
vulnerable older adults during this
difficult time
by supporting meals on meals america
please consider donating to celebrate
the happy couple by
clicking the link in our bio so they let
meals on wheels make the announcements
so that
meals on wheels would get press and
more donations okay it seems bizarre
because
like literally two of the richest people
in the world like why don't you just
give the money to wheels on wheels
well i'm going to assume that they are
going to need it but then they're also
just using this opportunity
for philanthropic cause and as someone
who's very steeped in philanthropy
yes your book made sure to mention that
25 times
i think this is a wonderful idea
congratulations to the ghosts
yeah brothers trying to get them invited
to the next part i want to host snl
colin let me on
i'll show you a real party called
honestly i feel like
that could happen that could happen 100
i think i would be fabulous
let me on colin i'll show you a real
party
the party like the crown by the way
that's
definitely like a remote possibility in
the next five years at least meghan
markle
either oh we could do it together i feel
like we're more likely to see harry than
we are
she could perform i could sing my
favorite song
what's your favorite song brother
what's your favorite song brother
brother there's an endless world
to re-discover
hey granny
hey he's like so [ __ ] crazy
hey brother
it's a [ __ ] bump grab oh my god your
face looked
[ __ ] nuts like oh my god
my stomach has scratched grand i have to
go party
grand you have some pepto-bismol grand
no oh my god oh my god
this is too funny okay well
congratulations to the jokes can't wait
to see you in new york when i'm be
traveling there dude you're like the
thirsty prince like
literally like you're using every story
it's like come to my house and want to
see joe calling like
you're being [ __ ] wrong crack some
jokes man yes colleen and i've got lots
of jokes for setting in our lives
oh my god the thirsty prince
the thirsty prince will not prince no
more the thirsty duke of sussex
not even not a thirsty american citizen
the thirsty commoner that's literally
what you are
coming out can't relate can't relate
commoner i live in a palace
okay next story about some other
brothers
who love brothers we love the jonas
brothers oh you know the jonas brothers
played at a state dinner
oh you must have mistake as you were out
um dressing up as a nazi yes that's what
you were doing yes yes yes
how could we forget but that weekend the
jonas brothers they were big in america
big big
quite large large thank you it's hard to
say big in a british accent
large in america at the time they were
these very talented young brothers
and yes you were busy like i said
dressing up as a nazi in a hotel room in
las vegas
but you miss this state dinner where
dinner where the jonas brothers
performed
grand quite enjoyed them right gran
quite enjoyed that it was a lovely
evening lovely what's your favorite song
gran
i like burning up gran and you also like
that new one
oh roller coaster roller coaster that
was sucka
yes sucker that's the one you like grand
no i like rolling positions
i know what i like i know what i like
gran i'm telling you we've got it on
vinyl for you
oh grand for your grandma phone but yes
like i said
that's like where you could play a
record grammar phone right yes but
harry he wasn't there where was he oh
right yes he was
dressing up as a nazi continued to bring
that up brother
i just couldn't remember why you weren't
at the state dinner and then i
remembered
oh right it's because you were dressing
up well oh
yeah as a nazi i'm sorry
you must have been hanging out with
jeffrey with granddaddy philip
too much shade well our favorite other
brothers the jonas brothers are ready
for the holidays with a new song i need
you
christmas it's so good it's so good so
christmas came early for the jonas
brothers fans including queen eliza
snitch
the band of brothers released in
nostalgic dripped christmas ballad
thursday called i need you christmas the
lyrics of which celebrate the kind of
joy 2020 could really use right now
it's a really good it's hard to make
original christmas music pretty much
everyone just puts out like an
album of covers they did one last year
too it's really good this one i really
enjoyed that last year
um you know their faces were all in the
ornaments for the promo
oh yeah oh my god i can't remember yeah
but this one's good i think this one
might make the jackie ho ho ho playlist
oh what a prestigious honor yes i like
the song a lot nick actually sounds very
good on it you know i take any ever
opportunity to jab at nick but he sounds
really good
yeah i'm just talking back to toast
weens of years past where the jonas
brothers were on this show
we're on the same show that the jonas
brothers were once on brother gran who's
your favorite brother
joe joe because i love sophie turner oh
were you a fan of the game of thrones
is the mother jewel of this country gran
truly making great britain proud
all across the u.s we love sophie
we love sophie we do and we love that
show don't we ground we used to watch
together
no we didn't before you left the family
for good well that was
after the finale i said why would i stay
here there's nothing to watch on tv
there's nothing left for me here
no more sundays with graham i'm gone
gran
what do you say we get a spot of tea
after this harry sorry i know you can't
come but grand spot of tea i would love
one great maybe some um
yeah cookies yes i'll have the butler i
like them now i'm hungry too gran
could i have you don't get to eat don't
they have um
mcdonald's where you're from yes it's
very good thank you for reminding me i'm
going to go for a mcflurry
okay next story next story this is
actually really beautiful kanye west
gave kim kardashian
a hologram of her dad for her birthday
holograms are the new candygram kim
kardashian revealed that husband kanye
surprised her with an unusual president
for her
40th birthday this week a hologram
message from her deceased father robert
kardashian
kim announced the gift on twitter
calling it the most thoughtful gift of a
lifetime and a special surprise from
heaven
it is so lifelike she added we watched
it over and over filled with emotion
robert who died in 2003 says you're 40
and all grown up
you look beautiful just like when you
were a little girl i watch you and your
sisters
and brothers and the kids every day well
you know i saw a lot of people being
like this is so weird like
please don't ever do this for my
birthday and
even megan mccain was like this and you
know megan mccain is very vocal about
like grieving
her down she was like honestly like
nobody please don't ever do this for me
like it's so
new i think it's so nice but see the
thing is that the kardashians lost their
dad at like a similar age that we did
and it's like honestly when you lose
your dad at a young age and it's
literally been so long like you
literally forget like what they look
like and like their mannerisms
so i could see how people would think
that this is weird but i actually think
we relate to the kardashians and i think
that this is actually
very cool because so much time has
passed and you were so young and like
you didn't get that much time with them
like megan mccain lost her dad now like
she's
i don't know how old she is but she's in
her 30s like that's a lot of time where
it's like kim and everyone they lost
their time when they were like 15 16. so
that's like when we did
and you like literally don't remember
them so like a hologram is like crazy
crazy when i when i first read the
headline i was like oh this is gonna be
weird and then i watched the video and i
was just like thinking of what that
would be like
for us if it were for us and like that
would be the most amazing thing
especially because like people who have
lost their
parents as adults like your parent has
like met your partner met your
hopefully met your kids like pictures of
them on your phone
he's where your life is now and has told
you that they're proud of you
but if you've lost a parent like 10 15
20 years ago and then they
literally are being brought to life and
like right the sweetest things
i think that this is like the most
amazing gift ever like literally a gift
from heaven
and it did seem extremely lifelike yeah
i thought it was so sweet and like
people were like making fun of it i just
feel like kim's having a bad week but
i loved it i thought it was so sweet and
like i understood exactly why she
thought it was so special
yeah like honestly it's the most
creative gift i've ever
100 heard of and people aren't
some people they're not here for it and
i actually can understand that because
when i saw the headline i was like
nah but in practice i think it's an
amazing gift
it's not it's truly not for everyone no
but i think there are people who would
absolutely
appreciate it so if anyone wants to make
me a hologram let me know
how much do you think that is i don't
know i feel like he just has hologram
technology in his studio
right like put it towards this and like
elon musk just like came over and
programmed it
yeah like i think it was free yeah like
you make holograms of like
artists on tour you can you know he
probably just went into that studio like
book some time and made right
a hologram but i guess like i don't know
i don't understand how they can like
get his like mannerisms and his voice
yeah and he's like
in language saying like things poofy
yeah i'm sure they used old videos and
stuff it really is interesting
you know i thought it was really sweet
and very cool and i liked it
i liked it too i understand not for
everyone but i'm here for it
me too are you ready for our fifth and
final story a thief in final yeah yeah
and fine yeah bruv let's do it bro
because
someone you mentioned elon musk grimes
reveals her five-month-old son with elon
musk
is into radical art he just actually is
no i mean i too what's radical as
grandmother at
five months i was into literature that's
why i'm going to be the next king and
not you
but literature radical art like lots of
well elon i think this is fabulous if
you want to give me a call let's
talk about it the thirsty prince strikes
again
grimes has a mini art critic on her
hands the singer revealed that her son
at nearly six months old
is already forming his own opinions in
an interview with the new york times
arguing that babies do have taste she
said that they definitely like some
things
they don't like other things they fully
have opinions i do agree with that but i
wouldn't necessarily like call
actually i think i would call kayla an
art critic so that's what i was gonna
say so our
niece michaela is similar age as a ex-12
angel 52 97 81 and
she calls him x for short by the way got
it um i think that michaela
is definitely showing signs of like
extreme interest in
radical art and literature and poetry
and cinema and i believe that
five-month-olds are definitely
while they may not articulate their
interests they definitely have
very strong views on radical art i agree
like my son archie he's a
radical art critic as well if you want
to get the kids together elon maybe we
could talk
shop shop shop shop brother i could tell
you're losing your british accent quite
a bit ever since
journeying over to the stage yes the
states have been very influential on me
howdy y'all i'm prince harry how y'all
doing
it's me prince harry all the way from
cambridge
now living in montecito monaco that's
fast how's montecito oh brother you've
got to come this time of year it is
fabulous none of that british rain and
sludge
we've got sunshine and bikinis you've
got sunshine and
and poor air quality so i hope you
enjoyed that brother
thank you brother nothing like the
british always raining on my parade no
wonder your bread always raining
hey gran how you doing graham grand
it's grand it's great
fabulous i'm hungry
please join me now don't worry we'll get
a spot of tea after this and i'll take
care of you i'll get you biscuits and
crumpets and all the things you like
scones those little blueberry scones
that they make down at the bakery i know
you like those greg
yes i do gran could i come please grant
i'm so hungry
i don't think so no it's royals oily
stuff yeah grass sorry brother
i couldn't use this water tea but you
could you could try why don't you go get
a coffee
yeah yeah oh why don't you go with your
with your new york friends and get some
coffee harry
oh grant
let's move into our tv recap segment yes
let's move right into it i've been
watching a lot of tv in america they've
got fabulous shows
the reality tv uh that we was on last
night was keeping up with the
kardashians and southern charm started
yes i watched kardashians first let's
start there okay i watched southern
charm first so brother how do we know
who gets to go
first oh brother it's an age-old
question between us
keeping up kardashians um it was really
good actually like
i feel like in a lot of ways it felt
like a psa for like coronavirus
yeah i mean it really did and it was
virtually filmed which is
so crazy but they did an amazing job
with the two camera angles and then they
had
uh interviews that they clearly like
filmed in their homes months later and
i thought they did such a good job like
i didn't feel like i was watching like a
torture
virtual experience i totally agree i
thought tech wise it was really really
well done
and how much like they were willing to
show cause like kim was literally with
the four kids kanye was quarantined and
i don't think she had any of her staff
so she was literally like taking care of
all four kids full-time while they were
in school and still managed to film
and then chloe's like literally on
death's door and she's still managing to
film too but it's like where was
courtney
you know yeah oh i guess then they
showed like courtney and scott went to
palm springs
yeah with the kids which was cute and
it's nice to see them like together and
like put some like
pieces together with the headlines like
me and scott are quarantined together
like what does this mean it
means that they both love their kids and
want to spend time with them um i loved
like
seeing so much of chloe's bedroom like
it's literally the most beautiful
bedroom
same thing i'm like i felt bad that she
was so sick and like literally couldn't
leave her room but i'm like of all the
places to be quarantined like
her live her bedroom has like a living
room off the side and then like her i'm
sure her master bed
bathroom is so sick like i was obsessed
with her room too like her bed looks
so comfortable so comfortable she's
really like has a nice decorating style
i feel like her
decor is like the most unique no i feel
like kim's is like super unique but
chloe's is like the most livable and
like where you would actually want to
live
yeah yeah yeah kylie also though yeah
yeah oh yeah kylie you got a little bit
of kylie yeah yeah
yeah it's like kind of lame no and it's
also like give me something or not
yeah and she already like shared that on
snapchat like that was a story like that
she had said that she had to quarantine
for her pregnancy but by the way kim
literally looked
so beautiful like running around
calabasas like just walking over to her
mom's house and like
walking around her house like while the
kids were in school like her face and
her hair like she looked so stunning
yeah she really did she really does it
all
i liked the episode because i felt like
it really symbolized what a lot of
people were going through in quarantine
which is like one being lonely
two like worrying worrying so deeply
about like your older family members
like when they were just like worried
for mj because like she had already been
quarantined for two months because of
her hip surgery
and now she wasn't gonna be able to
leave and like they were just like
crying and chris was like please call
mj today like it's so sad and that's
what like a lot of people were dealing
with
i feel like they actually did a really
good job of like capturing the
um like the vibe of what lockdown was
especially
like the first week yeah the first few
weeks like really
missing your family yeah and feeling
lonely
yeah but when kim was like should we go
to
wyoming like because she had a house
like that is just the vibe like to be
able to be like should we just like go
to wyoming
but they didn't no i know because of
connie couldn't fly
and neither could mj yeah
but when mj finally got to palm springs
i felt like a awakening
i was like what she should stay there
like she just went for lunch
i feel like like it i don't think she
was moving in like i think just
chris was just getting her out of the
house for like a day oh really yeah i
don't think she was staying there
but i feel like she should have me too i
don't know she probably has all her
things at home like
and likes her yes and i feel like the
older you get like everyone worries
about you in your house like you
actually like being home
yeah yeah well i thought it was a great
episode i felt so bad for chloe you
could actually tell
like when she was starting to feel
better like she was literally you know
when you get like really sick or like
you're really really not feeling well
and then like you feel so much better
and like you are literally so grateful
to god like
for this gift yeah she like she was
becoming like a preacher she was like
god bless us all the lord brought me out
of this like i know that feeling when
you're in
so much pain and you don't know like if
you're gonna die and like
god brings you out of it you become a
woman of god and like literally chloe
was like
praise be like god bless us all yeah she
said that like a million times i'm like
i knew exactly what she meant
i can't believe how bad she got it i
know like right at the beginning and she
even go to paris like
she was like being super careful and it
was crazy how they were like coming
and chloe were so sick like so so sick
and they were like
maybe it's corn and now it's like if you
have those symptoms like
finished but it was very dramatic kim
kardashian west test negative yes
kanye west positive chloe kardashian
positive it was really like
eerie yeah very eerie really good
episode really well done filming i think
some of the best virtual content if not
the best
i agree i agree and good for kim and
chloe once again for putting the show on
their backs
right even when chloe was literally on
death store right like she literally
just set up a camera like 24 hours in
her room while she was being
like miserable it's not like she turned
it on to like go cough in her bed like
she was just like letting herself be
filmed like being so sick
totally um and then southern charm was
back
and you know what i actually thought it
was like a great episode it
usually is yeah and i love um that new
guy
like i really ship him in madison i know
okay so we need to talk about there's a
new is he a new cast member was that
like a noun
yes there's two yes and that girl who's
friends with cameron yes
and so this is what i think happened
because um i remember her from other
seasons and like she's really like one
of cameron's best friends and i think
cameron brought her on the show and was
like
come on the show and it was like great
and then i think like cameron was
supposed to do this season but heard
that like
it was starting off with like catherine
talking about her husband having an
affair and she was like
nope i'm done with the show like [ __ ]
this yeah and that's why her friend's on
it but she's not and that's why they
were like is cam coming to the party
because like they weren't sure they
wouldn't ask that about someone who's
not a cast member anymore
but they thought she was still going to
be a cast member and it's clear that
she decided like once they started
filming like no no i'm not doing this
anymore
and even though like catherine was so
wrong to say those things especially if
they're not true and even if they are
true like it's just not her business
like
i understand why catherine is i'm sorry
no i'm 100 on team catherine
like i understand why catherine will be
mad at cameron for
the day she dies yeah and by the way
it's i don't
i don't know if those rumors are are
aren't true but i heard them too
and it was like maybe a year ago
probably around the time that this was
filming like i heard all that there were
all those like instagrams of people
being like i met her husband whatever
like there were legitimate rumors and
like what why does cameron get protected
when literally katherine's rehab
her custody her relationship with thomas
none of them none of that got protected
like it was literally
all put on display and cameron was like
this self in in
she put herself in charges like the
moral compass of the show so like she
was the narrator like whatever she said
goes
whatever she like do you like whoever's
like she was against you were against
she literally
i'm so team catherine you hold so much
of the dislike against she did apologize
yeah and she knows that and like we all
know that but
i am she never got her ass handed to her
in the way that she deserved it and the
way that she handed it to so many people
even though like we love her and she's
like so funny and she is such a great
person like
she was real she really went really hard
on catherine for a number of years
and now catherine and she was wrong now
catherine can finally get her revenge
and i don't like think that that's how
it
should go an eye for an eye but i
understand why catherine feels that way
100 no i was actually like
i'm like go like the way that she did it
more intentionally whereas like cameron
the way what she did to
catherine was like over many years and
was way more sneaky
but i don't know part of me just like
did not feel bad at all like yeah
sorry first of all this is what it's
like on a reality show and b especially
this type of reality show where people's
dirty laundry has been aired
for years and most of it was catherine's
yeah i understand my catherine like i
i wouldn't have done it but i understand
my catherine didn't care and catherine
was just gonna say
and she looks great catherine has
finally embraced a middle part and i'm
so excited about it yeah and when they
were flashing back to like
the things that catherine has cameron
has said about catherine they didn't
even really choose the worst ones they
just like chose ones where she was like
not interested in catherine drama but
like she
was very hard on catherine for so many
years i agree 100
so that's how i feel about that i think
craig is like literally the world's best
friend like he's able to be a friend to
catherine
and cameron at the same time um
and i think everything that he did in
that situation was right like he knew
that this shouldn't come up on camera
like he's
and he told that to catherine yeah he's
telling cameron what's happening
i think he's doing a great job what i
like about southern charm is that like i
really
genuinely like most of the cast yeah me
too and honestly like i was really
hating shep last season
but i feel like he's having like a come
to jesus moment he's in a relationship
he started therapy like
he like he was such an [ __ ] last
season especially to madison and then
that instagram story thing
i can't believe they put that in the
show like yeah he was just obviously
like in a bad place in his life and i
like
love that they're addressing it head-on
and it seems like he's really like in a
good place with like this very
normal girl who's like bringing him down
to earth yeah no i
i look forward to watching the rest of
that journey
also oh this is what i was saying i
genuinely like most of the cast and the
people who like i've hated
are gone me too like ashley landon
yep thomas i thought seeing thomas was
chills chilling it was so eerie
yes and he's part of the cast now from
what i've heard
really yeah i thought like or maybe not
like a full
cast member but like he's gonna be on
the show and i just think that is so
weird i think it's wrong
i think it's wrong and it was so weird
to see him and the other person who i
[ __ ] hate who never got what was
deserved because i guess
patricia no oh we should talk about her
jd
oh agreed but he was also never a
full-time cast member no but like he
did so much damage and so much [ __ ]
talking and another one who just went so
hard on catherine
and then all his chickens came to roost
and we never saw it on the show it was
just like in charleston press like
literally like bankrupt and a fraud and
like a literal piece of [ __ ] and like a
predator
yeah so that like i'm glad that all the
people that i really don't like are
gone it makes it much more pleasant to
watch to watch a bunch of people who
like i actually think
are good people and i i love madison and
austin i don't know if they're end game
because like
when she was just talking to that guy
and like they have kids and it's like
it's true like uh and patricia said it
really well like austin is a frat boy
and like
yes madison is just in a different place
in her life like she has kids and she's
really so mature like even just watching
her morning routine with her kid like my
god she's so busy and austin's still
asleep like
i actually feel what patricia was saying
yes i feel like what she was saying too
and
i want to see where this goes maybe it
will even if
i do sort of think madison and austin
are in game they like can't quit each
other yeah and she's like such a smart
girl yeah she just loves him so but
maybe her
you know wandering off with like this
guy will
inspire austin to step it up yeah but
like we've been waiting for austin
we were waiting for all these dudes like
stepping up like since we met them but
craig i'm stepping in i'm just gonna say
that
shep is trying to step it up yep i agree
so
yeah patricia i just hate her like
i just don't understand why this older
woman is why was she at chep's party
again she was like where's the cage ring
i'm like this is a [ __ ] party where
people get blacked out but
you want to go to dinner go across the
street to the state house but like
that's not what it is
like she like her being at that party
makes no sense like and her like having
parties at her house dinner parties at
her house we're literally every person
there's 30 years
old like makes no sense and i just think
like if we're not gonna
you know at least talk about how weird
it is
then i can't get on board i feel like
you and i always talk about how weird it
is and it's like
finally she's coming around but she is
another one who was so
so horrible about katherine and
catherine has forgiven her
and they've moved on and they have a
friendship but
i just feel like so much so many people
in this cast were just on the wrong side
of history i know and i don't know how
catherine works with them like they're
so evil
i know but you know catherine's not
perfect either
so yeah it's that's and they they're
really all seem to be like
actually friends yeah and that's why the
show really works i thought it was a
good episode it looks like it's going to
be a really good season
one person who left who i miss is
chelsea yeah i really liked her and
naomi and naomi
but i understand like i understand i
actually respect people who know when to
walk away
agreed like tinsley like yeah you know
there's a time for everything and
there's also a time
to say goodbye and so and for you
apparently that was this year when you
decided to move to canada
yes 2020's been a crazy one hasn't it
been brother
well honestly at buckingham palace it's
been relatively
unchanged seeing as how the staff has
all been quarantined with us
and we're really living at regular
regular pace although a lot of our state
visits
have been derailed which has been lovely
for grant and i we're spending lots of
time in the garden drinking tea
she's gotten very very close with
catherine my wife i don't know if you
know her
um and it's just been wonderful for the
family we've never been closer wouldn't
you agree grant it's true
well i've never been closer with my
family brother so i'm glad we're all
living the lives that we
so choose yes i i agree brother and you
know
after all is said and done family's
family
family is family put her there
oh brother oh clammy oh my god
i've got a lot on my plate brother
anything else the royals want to say
before we wrap up this toasterween 2020.
gran thank you for coming on our show
thank you for having me it is an
honor to have a woman of your stature
truly an honor
great we miss you i miss you guys oh yes
snitch
like we have switch on the two under
here too we haven't had the snitch cam
in forever how are you did you miss us
yes i did but you're living life and
you're just happy and you don't want to
come back here
exactly how's knowles she's so good
she's fabulous she's really growing up
it's really
sad but she's she's great she's got her
own personality like
she is in another world she's gonna get
a cell phone soon like me texting all
her friends like
you wanna ask her harry how oh how's
bruno i mean like i had asked off camera
but yeah he's really good he's so cute i
met him yesterday and little what did
you think of the man
so [ __ ] cute like oh my god like i
love him
so much he's so he he just has like such
a great energy you know
he's very zen i feel like he can't
believe you have a puppy
i know it's so crazy i'm so excited to
get the
the group together they'll bring the
family together we literally have
so many dogs we have like what do they
call it like a troop
no like when you give birth like the
litter we have a litter we do we have so
many dogs we've gotta get the kids
together to play
yes bring him to the garden oh i forgot
you're not allowed back at [ __ ] maybe
give me a visitor's pass for the day
maybe for archie i'll talk to mother
about it
we'll talk to mother and we'll see
that's all i can say archie
doctor um anything else anyone wants to
say before we
wrap this mother up we hope everyone has
a happy happy halloween can't wait to
save healthy
margaret keep going and tell them vote
vote tell them all margaret what else do
they do
what else where else do you have to wash
your face wash your hands wash your
hands
wear your mouth be with people don't be
honest be nice to people
be nice treat people with kindness don't
troll anyone's instagram like yeah
mental health yeah just take care of
yourself guys it's hard out there
listen to the this is the [ __ ]
queen
the literal queen listen to her and as
always
god save the queen good and with that we
have a jew at you
god save the queen have a wonderful
weekend everyone we hope you enjoyed
toasterween 2020
and we will see you back on monday for a
regular episode
tata tata
you